يا اخي الكريم هو الذي حصل هو انفجارات
لن يرافقها او لم يسبقها على عكس التجارب
الاوروبي ثورات الاوروبي سبقها تدوير فكري
تنوير ديلي
ولذلك اعطت اكلها اعطت ثمارها في حين انه
انتفاضات العربيه لم يسبقها تنوير ديدي
وتنور فلسفي ولذلك سطت عليها جماعات
الاخوان المسلمين
نعم او الحركه
الربيع العربي
همم مؤيده
كثير مثلا يعني جماعات بعيده للتكفير هل
يمكن هل ان تصنع المستقبل لذلك فشلت هذه
الانتفاضه لذلك انا اقول جعل ربيع العربي
اذا سوف يحصل مستقبلا ولكن بعد ان يحصل
الربيع الفكري بعد ان يحصد التدوير الفكري
بعد ان ننتقل من لاهوت التكثير الى داهود
التنوير او من من الفهم التكفيري للدين
الى الفاكهه الفهم التدويره
والمتسامح المنفتح نحن نعيش الان في عصر
العولمه يوميا يمكن نلتقي بالامريكي او
بالفرنسي او بالهندي او الصيني لا نستطيع
ان نعتبرهم كفارا ونتعامل معهم ينبغي ان
نتعايش معهم ونحترم تراستهم تراست جديد
والثقافيه لكي يحترموا تراثنا ايضا من هذه
النح اشد ب همم وشفت الاخوه الانسانيه
وثيقه مكه المكرمه لانه ما تمشيان في
اتجاه الصحيح ولكن هناك تيار
التطرف يمشي في الاتجاه الغلط في اتجاه
المعاكس لحركه التاريخ شايف كيف كيف
التسجيل هو مصر على همم دهوت التكفير شايف
كيف هنا انا ضد هذا التيار انا معنى هوشه
التنوير انا مع مع سهم جديد كليه الدراسه
الديني العربي الاسلامي